From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. From the moment you get up in the morning, your brain is making choices. Do you hit the snooze button? Do you hit it a second time? For breakfast, are you going to have cereal or eggs? Coffee or tea? Every day, you grapple with hundreds of choices. To many people an abundance of options is a good thing.
来自NPR，这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦德塔姆。从你早晨醒来的那一刻起，你的大脑就在做决定。你要按贪睡按钮吗？你要再按一次吗？早餐你要吃麦片还是鸡蛋？咖啡还是茶？每天，你都要应对数百个选择。对许多人来说，丰富的选项是一件好事。
It signifies freedom and having control. You get to choose whether to spend your Saturday at a movie or at a baseball game. You decide whether to try the new restaurant down the block or stay in and cook. It's your call whether to take the job with the higher pay or the one with better work-life balance. But in recent months, with the spread of the coronavirus pandemic, the number of choices in our lives has suddenly shrunk dramatically. And going to a grocery store has become the equivalent of a special outing. Imagine looking this good for who?
它象征着自由和掌控力。你可以选择把周六的时间花在看电影上还是去看棒球比赛。你决定是去街角那家新开的餐厅尝试一下，还是留在家里自己做饭。选择拿更高薪水的工作还是工作与生活平衡更好的工作，全由你说了算。但最近几个月，随着新冠疫情的蔓延，我们生活中的选择数量突然急剧缩减。去杂货店买东西甚至成了特殊远足般的体验。想象一下，长得这么好看是为了谁？
One mark. Look at this good for what? The constraints on our choices have been very hard. Millions of people are out of work, and millions more feel their lives are precarious. If we had a choice to swiftly go back to the old normal, we'd jump in it. But with all this hardship, many people also report a new relationship to the limited things they do have. Being homebound has given me the opportunity to not feel so rushed to stick to the rigid schedule that my family is used to.
一个标志。看看这长得这么好看是为了什么？对我们选择的限制一直非常严厉。数百万人失业，更多的人感到生活朝不保夕。如果我们有选择能迅速回到过去的正常生活，我们一定会毫不犹豫地跳进去。但伴随着所有这些艰难困苦，许多人也报告了他们与自己仅拥有的有限事物之间的一种新关系。居家隔离让我有机会不再那么匆忙地去遵守家人习惯的那种死板日程。
I've had to notice that I seem to be enjoying the mundane tasks of daily life a lot more than I used to do. Take the leaves out of my flower beds, make chocolate chip cookies with my tile. The other night I actually enjoyed just doing the dishes kind of spacing out into that. Would we be better off when our regular lives resume if we had fewer choices? Why do we crave so many options of ice cream, cars and vacation destinations? This week on Hidden Brain, what are choices say about us? Why we fail to understand the pernicious effect of too many choices? And how to make choices more wisely.
我不得不注意到，我似乎比以前更享受日常生活中的那些琐事了。比如清理花坛里的落叶，和我的泰尔一起做巧克力曲酯饼干。前几天晚上，我竟然很享受洗碗的过程，那种思绪放空的感觉。如果我们的常规生活恢复时选择更少，我们会过得更好吗？为什么我们渴望那么多的冰淇淋、汽车和度假目的地的选项？本周的《隐藏的大脑》，选择对我们意味着什么？为什么我们无法理解过多选择带来的恶劣影响？以及如何更明智地做出选择。
Shina Ayangar is a psychologist at Columbia University. She is best known for a bold idea that many people find surprising. Having more options doesn't always lead to better or happier decisions. In her book The Art of Choosing, she explores how history, culture and psychology shaped the way we think about making choices. Shina Aengar, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, it's wonderful to be here. A number of psychological studies have examined the well-being and motivation of people when they get to make choices about what they do. What have these studies generally found about the effects that choice and autonomy have on what's called intrinsic motivation? There's a wealth of studies that have been done with both animals
希娜·埃延加尔是哥伦比亚大学的心理学家。她以一个许多人觉得令人惊异的大胆想法而闻名。拥有更多选项并不总是能带来更好或更快乐的决定。在她的书《选择的艺术》中，她探讨了历史、文化和心理学是如何塑造我们思考做选择的方式的。希娜·埃延加尔，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，很高兴来到这里。许多心理学研究探讨了人们在有机会对自己的行为做出选择时的幸福感和动机。这些研究通常发现选择和自主权对所谓的内在动机有什么影响？有大量的研究对动物
and humans that show that when we have a feeling of control or a sense of autonomy over our lives, this makes us strive more, so we're more intrinsically motivated, it makes us healthier, it makes us happier, I mean, just lots of benefits when it comes to psychological and physical well-being. There's a famous study that looked at British bureaucrats that examined the differences in health between those who got to make decisions for others who were the bosses and those who had to follow orders, people who were underlings. What did the study find, Gina?
和人类都进行了研究，这些研究表明，当我们对自己的生活有一种掌控感或自主权时，这会让我们更加努力，也就是说我们会有更多的内在动机，它让我们更健康，让我们更快乐，我的意思是，在心理和身体健康方面有很多好处。有一项著名的研究调查了英国的官僚，考察了那些能够为他人（即老板）做决定的人与那些不得不听从命令（即下属）的人之间在健康方面的差异。这项研究发现了什么，吉娜？
The people that end up making more choices or having more autonomy and control over their schedules by and large were less likely to suffer from heart disease or strokes and lived longer lives. People who seemingly had less to worry about because all the choices were made for them, they were simply following orders, tended to be more stressed out and suffered more physical consequences for it. There are studies that show that giving people even trivial or superficial choices can improve their health. Alan Langer and Judy Rodin ran a remarkable study at a nursing home and can etiquette many
那些最终做出更多选择、或对自己的时间表有更多自主权和掌控权的人，总体上患心脏病或中风的可能性更小，寿命也更长。那些看似需要担心的事更少的人，因为所有的选择都为他们做好了，他们只是听从命令，往往压力更大，并为此承受了更多的身体后果。有研究表明，即使给予人们微不足道或肤浅的选择也能改善他们的健康。艾伦·兰格和朱迪·罗丁多年前在一家疗养院进行了一项卓越的研究。
years ago. Can you describe that study and tell me what it found? If you take people at a nursing home and you give them trivial choices, like would you like a plant in the room? Would you like to decide which night you watched the movie? You know, it's really trivial choices. It turns out that they end up having better health and they live longer, was essentially what they found.
你能描述一下那项研究并告诉我它的发现吗？如果你把人们带到疗养院，给他们一些微不足道的选择，比如你房间里想要一盆植物吗？你想决定哪天晚上看电影吗？你知道，这真的是微不足道选择。事实证明，他们最终拥有更好的健康并且活得更久，这基本上就是他们所发现的。
And you see these kinds of effects in all kinds of ways, right? If you give children a choice of when they're going to do their assignment, they spend more time on it, they're more motivated to do it. If you go into a restaurant that has higher ceilings, it gives you more delusion of freedom or a sense of space and liberty, again, people are happier. When you step back and look at the value of having choices, you've identified sort of three broad drivers that make choice valuable to have in our lives. What are those three drivers, Gina? I think choice plays three fundamental functions for us. First, it's just psychologically motivating. We feel happy when we have the feeling that we have autonomy or some kind of control. That's universal. The second is that compared to any other species on the planet, we can take a bunch of options
你会发现这种发现在各种方面都存在，对吧？如果你给孩子们一个选择他们什么时候做作业的机会，他们会在上面花更多的时间，他们做作业的动力更充足。如果你走进一家天花板更高的餐馆，它会给你更多自由的错觉或空间和自由感，同样，人们也会更快乐。当你退一步审视拥有选择的价值时，你已经确定了三大广泛的驱动因素，正是它们让选择在我们的生活中变得有价值。那三个驱动因素是什么，吉娜？我认为选择为我们发挥三个基本功能。首先，它本身就有心理上的激励作用。当我们感觉到自己有自主权或某种控制感时，我们会感到快乐。这是普遍存在的。第二点是，与地球上的任何其他物种相比，我们可以把一堆选项
and say, you know, which one is better or worse and make trade-offs. The function it plays is that it enables us to engage in judgment, decision-making. The third function that choice makes is it's because of our ability to choose that we're able to create new choices. We were able to imagine a future and turn that imagination into choices that we can now make. Having the freedom to imagine choices and to make those choices is a good thing. But is there a point at which we can have too much of this good thing? Many years ago, Shena was on a plane. The passenger sitting next to her Excitedly told her about a study she had read that had to do with jam
放在一起说，你知道，哪一个更好或更差，并做出权衡。它发挥的功能是使我们能够进行判断和决策。选择发挥的第三个功能是，正是因为我们有选择的能力，我们才能够创造新的选择。我们能够想象未来，并将这种想象转化为我们现在可以做出的选择。拥有想象选择和做出这些选择的自由是一件好事。但是，我们对这种好事的拥有会不会达到一个过量的程度呢？多年前，希娜坐在一架飞机上。坐在她旁边的一位乘客兴奋地告诉她一项她读过的关于果酱的研究。
What the passenger didn't know was that Sheena had conducted that study herself Lots of people do describe the jam study to me and they often refer to it as the jam study I did that study in the 1990s. There was this upscale grocery store called Draggers, which specialized in offering people lots and lots of choice. It had like 250 different types of mustard, vinegars, mayonnaisees, and over 500 different types of fruits and vegetables. In discussions with the manager, I asked the store managers to whether this model of offering
这位乘客不知道的是，希娜自己就进行过那项研究。很多人确实向我描述过果酱研究，他们经常把它称为果酱研究。我在20世纪90年代做了那项研究。当时有一家名为德拉格的高档杂货店，专门为人们提供大量繁多的选择。它大约有250种不同类型的芥末、醋、蛋黄酱，以及500多种不同类型的水果和蔬菜。在与经理的讨论中，我问店经理，这种为人们提供
people all this choice really worked. And after a series of discussions, we decided to do a little experiment, which has now been dubbed the Jam Study. So we set up a tasting booth where we put out six different flavors of Jam or 24 different flavors of Jam near the entrance of the store. And we looked at two things.
所有这些选择的模式是否真的奏效。经过一系列讨论，我们决定做一个小实验，现在这个实验被称为“果酱研究”。因此，我们在商店入口附近设立了一个品尝摊位，摆出了六种不同口味的果酱或24种不同口味的果酱。我们观察了两件事。
First in which case were people more likely to stop and sample some jam. It turned out more people stopped when they were 24 on display, 60% versus 40%. And then we looked at in which case were people more likely to buy a jar of jam. And it turned out that more people were likely to buy a jar of jam. And it turned out that more people were likely to buy a jar of jam when they encountered six than when they encountered 24. So again, the experiment had two conditions. In one, the researcher set up a table with six jams. In another, they had 24. More people stopped at the jam display when they were more options. more. More people stopped at the jam display when there were more options, but more people actually bought jam when there were fewer options.
首先是在哪种情况下人们更有可能停下来品尝一些果酱。事实证明，当展示24种时，停下来的人更多，比例为60%对40%。然后我们观察了在哪种情况下人们更有可能购买一罐果酱。事实证明，更多的人更有可能购买一罐果酱。事实证明，当人们遇到六种时，比遇到24种时，更多的人更有可能购买一罐果酱。所以再次说明，这个实验有两个条件。在一个条件中，研究人员摆了一张放有六种果酱的桌子。在另一个条件中，他们有24种。当有更多选项时，更多的人会在果酱展示台前停下来。更多。当有更多选项时，更多的人会在果酱展示台前停下来，但实际上当选项较少时，更多的人购买了果酱。
And this was really the first documentation that even though people are more attracted to having more choices, when it comes down to making a choice, they're more likely to make a choice when they have less than when they have more. I want to stay a moment with sort of the evolution of the idea after you did the jam study. You got a call from the Vanguard Group, which is one of the largest mutual fund companies in the world, and they were looking at some 900,000 employees at various companies, and they were looking at the number of people who were signing up to save for their retirement and 401k plans, and they were finding that as they provided more options
这确实是第一份文档记录：尽管人们对拥有更多选择更感兴趣，但在真正做出选择时，当选项较少时，他们比选项较多时更有可能做出选择。我想在你做完果酱研究之后，在这个想法的演变上停留一会儿。你接到了先锋集团的电话，这是世界上面向散户最大的共同基金公司之一，他们当时正在研究各个公司的约90万名员工，他们观察了注册为退休储蓄和401(k)计划存钱的人数，发现随着他们提供更多选项
to people, more mutual fund options, the number of people who were signing up to save for retirement was dropping. Tell me about the study you did with them and what it found. So it was about 900,000 people. They were all in the United States, about 650 different institutions.
给人们，提供更多共同基金选项，注册存钱准备退休的人数却在下降。跟我讲讲你和他们一起做的研究以及它的发现。所以当时大约有90万人。他们全在美国，大约有650家不同的机构。
And these companies ranged in size from a few hundred up to about 100,000 employees. They were all carrying a vanguard. That is a common factor across all of them. But essentially what we found was that these plans offered people anywhere from two to roughly 60 options. And what we found was that as plans offered, people more options participation rates dropped. And so the more choices you gave people,
这些公司规模从几百名员工不等，最多可达约10万名员工。他们都在使用先锋领航。这是所有这些公司共同的一个因素。但基本上我们发现的是，这些计划向人们提供的选项从两个到大约60个不等。我们发现的是，随着计划向人们提供更多选项，参与率下降了。所以你给人们的选择越多，
the lower the participation rates. And by the way, these are all cases where employees could expect a match from their employers. So they were literally giving up free money by not participating. When we looked at people who actually did participate to actually made the choice, even there we found that giving people more choices
参与率就越低。顺便说一句，在所有这些案例中，员工都可以期待雇主提供匹配资金。因此，他们如果不参与，实际上就等于放弃了免费的钱。当我们观察那些真正参与并真正做出选择的人时，即使在那个群体中，我们发现给人们更多选择
didn't actually make them better choosers. It turned out that the more choices we gave them, the more likely they were to avoid investing in equities and put more of their money in bonds and money markets. And you know, most of the time when you're talking about long-term financial well-being, you really shouldn't be avoiding equities. Vanguard wasn't the only company interested in questions of choice. Corporations seized on the idea that having fewer options could boost sales.
并没有真正让他们成为更好的选择者。事实证明，我们给他们的选择越多，他们就越有可能避免投资股票，而将更多的钱投入债券和货币市场。你知道，大多数时候当你谈论长期的财务健康时，你真的不应该避开股票。先锋并不是唯一对选择问题感兴趣的公司。企业抓住了提供更少选项可以促进销售的想法。
Proctor and Gamble reduced the number of options of their anti-Dandra shampoo and saw sales surge. It was a counter-intuitive pivot in a culture where the abundance of choice was seen as an inherent good. There was another domain where Shina found that having more choices didn't turn out the way people expected. As an undergraduate, she had spent time in Germany when the Berlin Wall came down. Thousands of East Germans came across the border today, perhaps more than a hundred thousand. So many, the border police. of a hundred thousand so many the butterflies. I was fascinated by Berlin and I was there when the
宝洁公司减少了其去屑洗发水的产品选项，结果发现销量激增。在将选择的丰富性视为一种内在美德的文化中，这是一个违反直觉的转变。希娜发现有更多的选择并不像人们预期那样发展的另一个领域是。作为一名本科生，当柏林墙倒塌时，她曾在德国待过。成千上万的东德人越过边界，今天也许超过了十万。人太多了，边境警察。
wall fell and participated in all the big partying and you know it's a wall fell and everybody's partying and hugging each other and this was a moment where freedom had prevailed it was a big deal. But when she now went back to Germany in the earlys, she found the euphoria had worn off. East Berliners would say, yes, I have more choices in terms of where I could go for vacation, more choices of what I can eat, but I've lost access to the better quality asparagus, because apparently better quality asparagus came from the East. And so they were questioning paragus came from the East. And so they were questioning whether having more choice was really worth it, that they felt that at some level they had lost out on some of the more high quality choices in
十万，人太多了，蝴蝶。我对柏林很着迷，墙倒塌时我正在那里，参与了所有盛大的派对，你知道，墙倒塌了，每个人都在聚会和拥抱，这是一个自由占了上风的时刻，这是一件大事。但当希娜在20世纪早期回到德国时，她发现这种狂喜已经消退了。东柏林人会说，是的，我在去哪儿度假方面有了更多选择，在吃什么方面有了更多选择，但我失去了获得更优质芦笋的机会，因为显然更优质的芦笋来自东方。因此他们在质疑，
the drive to have more choices. One of the most telling examples of the mismatch between our perception of the importance of choices and the reality of those choices is a personal story that you tell about your own parents. Tell me that story, Shina, and what you took away from it. When I was growing up in this culture, you always taught that you choose everything. I mean, you always ask what do you want. And of course, you're the one who decides how you're going to look and what you're going to do with your life in terms of your, you know, how you're going to look and
拥有更多选择是否真的值得，他们觉得在某种程度上，在追求更多选择的过程中，他们失去了一些更高质量的选择。关于我们对选择重要性的感知与这些选择的现实之间不匹配的最生动的例子之一，是你讲述的关于你自己的父母的一个个人故事。讲讲那个故事，希娜，你从中领悟到了什么。当我在这种文化中长大时，你总是被教导你要选择一切。我的意思是，你总是被问到你想要什么。当然，由你来决定你的外表，以及你将如何度过你的人生，就你的，你知道，你的外表和
what you're going to do with your life in terms of your career and obviously whom you're going to marry. And you know, my parents met each other on their wedding night. It was really decided by my two grimmas. And when I was growing up and I would tell everybody, yeah, my parents met each other on their wedding night, I kid you not, it never failed. Every single friend of mine, every single friend's parent would always say, Oh my God, if that ever happened to me, I would die.
你将如何度过你的人生，就你的职业而言，显然还有你要和谁结婚。你知道，我的父母在他们结婚的那天晚上才见面。这真的是由我的两个祖母决定的。当我长大了，我会告诉每个人，是的，我的父母是在他们结婚的那天晚上见面的，我没骗你，每次都这样。我的每一个朋友，每一个朋友的父母总是会说：“天哪，如果这种事发生在我身上，我就会死。”
And, you know, I certainly understood that that was the view. But my parents never really looked like they were ready to die. They, you know, they were just mom and dad. You know, they were just mom and dad. Contrary to the theories of her friends, Sheena's parents were not miserable. It was yet another example of the strange conundrum. When you limited people's choices, they didn't always turn out worse.
而且，你知道，我当然明白那是那种观点。但我的父母看起来从来没有准备好去死的样子。他们，你知道，他们只是妈妈和爸爸。你知道，他们只是妈妈和爸爸。与她朋友们的理论相反，希娜的父母并不痛苦。这又是那个奇怪难题的另一个例子。当你限制人们的选择时，他们的结果并不总是变得更糟。
When we come back, what are choices say about who we are and why many of us crave more choices, even when they make us unhappy? Psychology Shina AYANGAR teaches at Columbia Business School. She has studied the choices we make, why our choices don't always produce the results we intend, and how to make better choices. Shina, one idea you explore has to do with the perception that we all have about ourselves, that we are unique. What does this perception have to do with our desire for choice and how we make choices? So we all have an innate desire to be someone, right? We don't want it just to be a member of some massive crowd unrecognizable from everybody else. So we want to somehow stand out from everybody else. We don't want to become this lonely minority, but we do want to somehow be distinguishable from the person next to us.
当我们回来时，选择对我们是谁意味着什么，为什么我们中的许多人渴望更多选择，即使这些选择让我们不开心？心理学家希娜·埃延加尔在哥伦比亚商学院任教。她研究了我们所做的选择，为什么我们的选择并不总是产生我们预期的结果，以及如何做出更好的选择。希娜，你探讨的一个想法与我们所有人对自己的看法有关，即我们是独一无二的。这种看法与我们对选择的渴望以及我们如何做选择有什么关系？因此，我们都有一个与生俱来的愿望，想要成为某个人，对吧？我们不想只成为某个庞大群体中无法与其他人区分开来的普通一员。所以我们希望以某种方式从其他人中脱颖而出。我们不想成为这个孤独的少数派，但我们确实希望以某种方式与旁边的这个人有所区别。
And how do we do that? We do that through the expression of identity and more and more in the modern world that expression of identity is coming through the choices that we make. The more choices we have, the more we believe that we can identify and pick a choice that is the perfect expression of who I am and what I want. And so that's really the link between my desire to uniquely be known as a type of person and how choices are used to establish my uniqueness. What does the psychological research say about our perception of uniqueness? Is it actually true? Well, it's interesting that you ask that question.
我们是怎么做到的呢？我们通过表达身份来做到这一点，在现代世界中，这种身份的表达越来越多地通过我们所做的选择来实现。我们拥有的选择越多，我们就越相信我们可以识别并挑选出一个完美的选项，作为我是谁以及我想要什么的完美表达。所以这确实是我对独特地成为某种类型的人的渴望与如何利用选择来确立我的独特性之间的联系。心理学研究对我们的独特性感知是怎么说的？这真的是真的吗？嗯，你问这个问题很有意思。
So let's say I give you a bunch of things like names to call your children or sunglasses or shoes or ties for the case of men. And I ask you to just rate these on how unusual they are, how common they are. And I also ask you not only to rate on how unusual and common they are, but I also ask you how much do you like them, how much do you think other people would like them? And we did a series, we did this with a series of different kinds of decision-making scenarios. And what we found was that most people really believe that they like more unique things than everybody else.
所以，假设我给你一堆东西，比如给孩子取的名字、太阳镜、鞋子或男士领带。我让你对这些东西的不寻常程度、常见程度进行评分。我不仅让你对它们的不寻常和常见程度进行评分，还让你评价你有多喜欢它们，你认为其他人会多喜欢它们？我们做了一系列研究，在一系列不同类型的决策场景中做了这个。我们发现的是，大多数人真的相信他们比其他人更喜欢独特的东西。
They also believe that they are more unique than everybody else. But when you actually look at their preferences for what they like as compared to what other people said they like, essentially we all like the same thing. We want that which is considered to be slightly unique. Nothing to plan, nothing to bizarre. So like if you look at ties, right? We don't want to pick the tie with the, you know, with the orange disco balls on it, that's a little too weird. We also do want to pick just the solid color, that might be a little too boring. We want something we just a little bit of a kick to it.
他们还相信自己比其他所有人更独特。但当你真正审视他们对自己喜欢的东西的偏好与其他人说他们喜欢的东西相比时，本质上我们都喜欢同一样东西。我们想要那些被认为稍微独特的东西。既不高调，也不太古怪。比如你看领带，对吧？我们不想选择那种带有橙色迪斯科球的领带，那有点太奇怪了。我们也不想只选择纯色，那可能有点太无聊了。我们要的是那种有点新意的东西。
So we believe that we are unique and we need choices to express that uniqueness, but we then sometimes, as you say, find ourselves in the awkward situation of making choices that are not very different from others, which then challenges our notions of being unique. You tell a funny story about waiting in line for hours at an Apple store to buy an iPhone for your partner, and he gave you very specific instructions on what he wanted. Tell me what happened next, Gina. So this is my ex-husband, yes. For his birthday, it was just at the time when the Apple iPhone had just come out.
所以我们相信自己是独一无二的，我们需要选择来表达这种独特性，但正如你所说，有时我们会发现自己处于一种尴尬的境地，做出的选择与其他人并没有太大区别，这随后挑战了我们对独特性的看法。你讲了一个有趣的故事，讲述你在苹果店排队数小时为你的伴侣买iPhone，他对你想要什么给出了非常具体的指示。告诉我接下来发生了什么，吉娜。所以这是我的前夫，是的。在他生日那天，正好是苹果iPhone刚出来的时候。
And for his birthday, he wanted the original iPhone. So what happens was on that day, I don't know if you remember, but when the Apple iPhone first came out, there were these long lines that would go down many, many blocks. Six o'clock this morning. Well, more horrible, yeah, he spent the last 12 hours waiting at night. So I had to get up at the middle of the night and go down to the Apple store and stand in line
在他生日那天，他想要初代iPhone。所以发生的事情是，在那一天，我不知道你是否还记得，当苹果iPhone刚问世时，排着长队，队伍延伸了好几个街区。今天早上六点。好吧，更糟糕的是，是的，他在晚上排了过去12个小时的队。所以我不得不半夜起床去苹果店排队
to get him this phone that he really wanted for his birthday. And he had given me some very specific instructions that he needed the black iPhone. I gave him all these specifications, blah, blah, blah. He wanted the black one because he had said that it, you know, it's less likely to get dirty and it looks sleek, etc. Well, by the time I got to the front of the line, he caught up with me, he got out of bed, came to the Apple store and this is the one on Fifth Avenue, he got out of bed, he got to me and he's like,
给他买这部他生日时非常想要的手机。他给我一些非常具体的指示，他需要黑色的iPhone。他给了我所有的规格，啦啦啦。他想要黑色的，因为他说，你知道，它不太容易变脏，而且看起来很时髦等。好吧，当我排到队伍最前面时，他赶上了我，他从床上爬起来，来到了苹果店——这是第五大道的那家，他从床上爬起来，来到我身边，然后
just as I'm putting in the order for the black phone, he's like, no, no, no, switch that to the white. And I'm like, what do you mean you went the white? You told me you went at the black and you told me all these reasons why you wanted the black. And I didn't really care about black or white. What did I care? And he's like, I don't know, I haven't even looked around. Everybody else has got the black one. I want the white one. Now, mind you, we're only talking about black versus white. So as far as I was concerned, I really couldn't see the big deal here. Now, you know, and he was in the loan.
就在我为黑色的手机下订单时，他说，不，不，不，换成白色的。我说，你什么意思，你想要白色的？你告诉我你想要黑色的，你告诉我你想要黑色的所有理由。我其实并不在乎黑色还是白色。我在乎什么？他说，我不知道，我甚至都没环顾四周。其他人都有黑色的。我想要白色的。现在请注意，我们谈论的只是黑色与白色。所以就我而言，我真的看不出这有什么大不了的。现在，你知道，他独自一人。
There were lots of people who regularly make that decision just to which one's going to somehow make them stand out. Now, today, my understanding is he doesn't even carry any apple phone in part because they would make him look too cut-form-s. So it doesn't actually believe in apple products. So, so yes, we often do that. There are experiments along these lines of people sitting in a restaurant deciding what to order. Sometimes they get to be the first to make the order. Sometimes they have to wait for everyone around the table to order.
有很多人经常仅仅为了某种能让他们脱颖而出的原因而做出那种决定。现在，据我所识，他甚至都不用任何苹果手机，部分原因是那会让他显得太墨守成规。所以他实际上并不相信苹果产品。所以，是的，我们经常这样做。有沿着这些思路进行的实验，关于人们在餐馆里决定点什么。有时他们可以第一个点菜。有时他们必须等到桌子周围的每个人都点完。
Tell me what these experiments find and how satisfied people are with what they order depending on whether they go first or they go last. Well my favorite study is this study that we've done in a brewery where people are at a table and these are just normal customers at a table and they would ask people to order and so the first person would order the second person, third person, fourth person, fifth person. The orders of the first person were much more homogenous, meaning you were more likely to order similar things when you looked across the first orderers. But when you looked at the people who ordered it, each table subsequent to the first person, now
告诉我这些实验发现了什么，人们对自己所点菜品的满意度如何，这取决于他们是第一个点还是最后一个点。嗯，我最喜欢的研究是我们在啤酒厂做的一项研究，人们坐在一张桌子旁，这些都只是桌子旁的普通顾客，他们会要求人们点菜，所以第一个人点菜，第二个人，第三个人，第四个人，第五个人。第一个人的点菜要同质得多，这意味着当你纵观第一批点菜的人时，你更有可能点类似的东西。但当你看着每个桌子上继第一个人之后的那些人时，现在
you saw greater heterogeneity. Right? So the second, third, fourth, fifth person, they're all ordering something slightly different from the person who just ordered right before them. Interestingly enough, the person who's most satisfied with the beer that they ordered is the first person who ordered because they weren't paying any attention to what everybody else had already ordered.
你看到了更大的异质性。对吧？所以第二、第三、第四、第五个人，他们点的东西都与刚刚在他们之前点菜的人略有不同。有趣的是，对自己所点啤酒最满意的人是第一个点菜的人，因为他们根本没有注意其他人已经点了什么。
Another issue with having choices is that it forces us to grapple with options that we have to forego. I'm wondering how this worry might affect the world of dating when we have so many people we can potentially choose from, but making a choice involves foregoing other choices. Oh, it's a huge problem, right? It's what we call FOMO, Barry Schwartz and I first identified it in the domain of job search, right? It's what we call FOMO, very short tonight first identified it in the domain of job search, right? That when people get more job opportunities, even though they actually do
拥有选择的另一个问题是，它迫使我们去应对我们不得不放弃的选项。我想知道，当我们有这么多潜在的选择对象时，这种担忧可能会如何影响约会世界，但做一个选择就意味着放弃其他选择。哦，这是一个巨大的问题，对吧？这就是我们所说的FOMO（错失恐惧症），巴里·施瓦茨和我最早在求职领域发现了这一点，对吧？这就是我们所说的FOMO，巴里·施瓦茨和我最早在求职领域发现了这一点，对吧？当人们获得更多的工作机会时，尽管他们在许多客观意义上实际上
better in many objective senses, right? They get higher salaries, they get better packages, they're less happy than the people that had fewer job offers. And the reason is not so much that they're convinced that they didn't pick the best of the bunch that they had. Most often they are convinced that they picked the best, but they are convinced that there might actually still be something better out there because they compare what they chose against some imaginary option. And the same thing is happening at a much larger level when it comes to dating, right?
做得更好，对吧？他们获得更高的薪水，他们得到更好的福利包，但他们比那些获得较少工作机会的人更不快乐。原因与其说他们确信自己没有从他们拥有的那堆东西中挑选出最好的，不如说大多数情况下他们确信自己挑选了最好的，但他们确信外面可能仍然有更好的东西，因为他们将自己选择的与某个想象中的选项进行比较。在约会方面，更大的层面上也正在发生同样的事情，对吧？
Because you have so many options. And you know, in many ways, these are incomparable options. Because you're comparing humans. And of course, it doesn't make a difference how long you go. There'll always be more options on the table. So this becomes a prescription then for indecision or a prescription for essentially dragging the decision out endlessly. Absolutely. So sometimes the choices we make are trivial, but other times they're also potentially heartbreaking.
因为你有这么多的选项。而且你知道，在许多方面，这些是不可比较的选项。因为你在比较人类。当然，你走多长时间都没有区别。桌面上总会有更多的选项。因此，这就成了优柔寡断的处方，或者本质上是无休止地拖延决定的处方。绝对的。所以有时我们做出的选择是微不足道的，但其他时候它们也可能是潜在的心碎时刻。
You describe in your book how researchers have looked at one of the worst tragedies to befall new parents and examine differences between countries like the United States and France. Can you tell me about those research studies and what they found, Shina? Yeah, those were some of the most heartbreaking studies I did, and yet so much of what we learned in those studies are so applicable to modern day society. Essentially, we did a study with parents in France
你在书中描述了研究人员如何研究降临在新手父母身上的最严重悲剧之一，并检查了美国和法国等国家之间的差异。你能告诉我那些研究以及它们的发现吗，希娜？是的，那些是我做过的最令人心碎的研究，然而我们在这些研究中学到的东西有那么多都非常适用于现代社会。本质上，我们对法国的父母
and parents in the United States who all had given birth to a child that was suffering from cerebral anaxia. Cerebral anaxia is a type of injury where the brain is deprived of oxygen. As a result, Sheena says, these children were born with little or no brain function. In the case of France, the doctors would make the decision of taking these babies off of life support. And in the case of the United States, the doctors would tell the parents that look, you know, the likelihood that this child will ever walk or talk or engage in any kind of normal life is close to zero. And so you can
和美国的父母进行了研究，他们都生下了患有脑缺氧的孩子。脑缺氧是一种大脑缺氧的损伤。结果，希娜说，这些孩子出生时几乎没有或完全没有大脑功能。在法国的情况下，医生会做出让这些婴儿拔除生命支持系统的决定。而在美国的情况下，医生会告诉父母，你看，你知道，这个孩子能走路、说话或从事任何正常生活的可能性接近零。所以你可以
either take it off life support or it will probably die anyway. And the American parents would have to sign the consent form in order for that final decision to be made. And so we compared those cases where the decision was made in both cases for the child to be made. And so we compared those cases where the decision was made in both cases for the child to be removed off of life support and in general in this kind of decision-making, it's very rare for a child not to be taken off of life support. And so when they are taken off of life support, they typically die within hours. Now what we did was we followed these parents over the course of the next year, and what we found was that the parents in the United States had a much harder time coping with the death of their child as compared to the ones in France. So the parents in France were much
要么拔除生命支持系统，要么无论如何他可能都会死。美国父母将不得不签署同意书，以便做出最终决定。因此，我们比较了在两种情况下都为儿童做出拔除生命支持系统的决定的案例，并且总的来说，在这种决策中，儿童不被拔除生命支持系统的情况是非常罕见的。因此，当他们被拔除生命支持系统时，他们通常会在几个小时内死亡。现在我们所做的是在接下来的一年里追踪这些父母，我们发现美国的父母在应对孩子的死亡时要困难得多，相比于法国的父母。所以法国的父母更有可能说这样的话，你知道，
more likely to say things like, you know, Noah was here for so little time, but in that time he gave us so much. Now by contrast, the American parents were still suffering even a year later. And they said things that were really heartbreaking like, you know, I keep wondering, what if, what if, what if, or they said things like, I can't believe they got me to do that.
诺亚在这里的时间很短，但在那段时间里他给了我们那么多。相比之下，美国父母甚至在一年后仍在痛苦。他们说了一些真正让人心碎的话，比如，你知道，我一直在想，如果……如果……如果……或者他们说了一些这样的话，我不敢相信他们让我那样做。
So it was almost like they were still struggling with the guilt and wanting to put their responsibility somewhere because they were struggling with the fact that essentially they felt they had killed their child. So did the American parents wish that they had not been given that choice in that situation? Well, the paradox in that study was that even though having made the choice, had made these Americans so miserable when they were asked, would you have rather have had the doctors make the choice for you?
所以这几乎就像他们仍然在与内疚作斗争，并希望把他们的责任推卸到某处，因为他们在与这样一个事实作斗争：本质上他们觉得他们杀了自己的孩子。那么美国父母是否希望他们在那种情况下没有被赋予那种选择呢？好吧，那项研究中的悖论是，尽管做出了选择让这些美国人在被问及“你是否宁愿让医生为你做决定”时感到如此痛苦
They all said no. And I think this comes back to the fact that in this culture, choice has a really special elevated place in our lives. Because for these American parents, to say no to choice would have made them question everything that they had come to believe was important to them and what it meant to be a human being. So even when we know that our choices can lead to great unhappiness, we cannot help wanting to have those choices anyway. We still
他们都说不。我认为这回到了这样一个事实：在这种文化中，选择在我们的生活中占有非常特殊的崇高地位。因为对这些美国父母来说，对选择说不，会让他们质疑他们已经开始相信对他们来说重要的一切，以及作为一个人意味着什么。因此，即使我们知道我们的选择会导致巨大的不幸，我们也还是忍不住想要拥有这些选择。我们仍然
believe we should be the one to make the choice. Questions of choice in autonomy are raging around us today in the context of the COVID-19 pandemic. Some people chafed being told to stay home and see it as a curtailment of their personal autonomy. I ask Shina how questions of choice are shaping our response to the pandemic. Well, I think that one of the lens through which we see choice around the globe has to do with to what extent we value the notion of individualism versus collectiveism. And so when you go to places like China,
相信我们应该是做出选择的那个人。在当今新冠肺炎疫情的背景下，关于选择和自主权的问题在我们周围甚嚣尘上。有些人对被告知待在家里感到恼火，并将其视为对自己个人自主权的削减。我问希娜，选择的问题是如何塑造我们对疫情的反应的。嗯，我认为我们看待全球选择的视角之一，与我们在多大程度上重视个人主义与集体主义的概念有关。因此，当你去像中国这样的地方时，
having a decision dictated to you in the interest of the collective feels more natural. In the case of the United States, having a choice dictated to you in the interest of the collective feels a bit foreign because this is a culture that above all else values individual rights. That is the collective stand. And now we're asking people to do something that's kind of antithetical to that, which is put aside your own individual interests for the sake of the collective.
为了集体的利益而由他人向你发号施令的感觉更自然。在美国的情况下，为了集体的利益而让你遵从某种选择的感觉有点陌生，因为这是一种高于一切重视个人权利的文化。那是集体立场。而现在我们要求人们做一些与此相悖的事情，那就是为了集体的利益而把个人的利益放在一边。
Whether you're living in a culture that prizes the collective or prioritizes the individual, there are ways to make better decisions. When we come back, how to make WIZER choices? Shina Iangar studies how we make choices and how we can make better choices. One of our earlier studies involves students at an elementary school in San Francisco. One of my first studies on choice looked at the differences between Asian and Anglo-American children. And essentially, we took a very traditional paradigm in psychology where in one condition children are given a choice, which one of these six activities do you want to do, and
无论你生活在崇尚集体还是优先考虑个人的文化中，都有办法做出更好的决定。当我们回来时，如何做出更明智的选择？希娜·埃延加尔研究我们如何做选择以及我们如何能做出更好的选择。我们早期的研究之一涉及旧金山一所小学的学生。我关于选择的第一项研究着眼于亚裔和英裔美国儿童之间的差异。本质上，我们在心理学中采用了非常传统的范式，其中在一个条件下给孩子们一个选择，你想做这六项活动中的哪一项，
in the other condition the children are told which one of these six activities do you want to do? And in the other condition, the children are told which one of these six activities to do. We then added a third condition, where the children were shown the choices, but were told that their mothers had made the choice for them, as to which of the six activities they would do. And these are seven year old kids. And what we found was that with Anglo-American children, we got exactly what prior research had expected us to find. Anglo-American children were more motivated to do the activity and performed better on
在另一个条件下，孩子们被告知你想做这六项活动中的哪一项？在另一个条件下，孩子们被告知要做这六项活动中的哪一项。我们随后添加了第三个条件，在这个条件中，孩子们看到了选项，但被告知他们的母亲已经为他们做出了选择，决定他们将做这六项活动中的哪一项。这些是七岁的孩子。我们发现，对于英裔美国儿童，我们得到了先前研究所期望的结果。英裔美国儿童更有动力去做这项活动，并且在做出选择时表现得更好。
the activity when they made a choice. And it didn't matter whether it was an experimenter who made the choice for them or their mothers. If anything, they were more angry when they were told that their mothers had made the choice for them or their mothers. If anything, they were more angry when they were told that their mothers had made the selection for them. And so Anglo-American children were more likely to say things like, you asked my mother, I can't believe you asked my mother. By contrast, the, and I can relate now
这并不重要，无论是实验人员为他们做出选择还是他们的母亲。如果有的话，当被告知他们的母亲为他们做出了选择时，他们更加愤怒，或者他们的母亲。如果有的话，当被告知他们的母亲为他们做了挑选时，他们更加愤怒。因此，英裔美国儿童更有可能说这样的话：“你问了我母亲，我不敢相信你问了我母亲。”相比之下，而且我现在可以作为一个十几岁孩子的母亲产生共鸣。
as a mother of a teenager. I mean, I think you would kill somebody if they said that mom had the right to make a choice for him. Now, by contrast, the Asian American children, they actually performed the best for mother. When they thought mom had made the choice, second best when they got to choose for themselves, and you know, just as badly as the Anglo-American children when the choice was made for them by this experiment or whom they had never met before. What we observed there was that for the Asian American children, having mom
我的意思是，如果你说妈妈有权为他做选择，我想你会杀了某人的。相比之下，亚裔美国儿童，他们实际上为母亲做得最好。当他们认为妈妈做出了选择时，当他们自己做选择时排名第二，你知道，当选择是由这个他们从未见过面的实验人员为他们做出时，他们和英裔美国儿童一样糟糕。我们在那里观察到的是，对于亚裔美国儿童来说，让妈妈
make the choice was not this awful thing. If anything they wanted mom to be told that they had done it exactly the way she had said. Because for them it wasn't this moment of someone taking away their empowerment. If anything, they felt more empowered by having Mother make the choice, because now they felt more confident that they were making the right choice. So some of this has to do with our notions of how much we think of ourselves as individuals, how much we see ourselves as part of a collective. It's not necessarily that, you know, Asian and Anglo children are biologically different from one another.
做出选择并不是一件可怕的事情。如果有的话，他们希望妈妈被告知他们完全是按照她所说的那样做的。因为对他们来说，这并不是某人夺走他们赋权的时刻。如果有的话，通过让母亲做出选择，他们感到了更多的赋权，因为现在他们对自己的选择是正确的更有信心。因此，这其中一部分与我们关于我们将自己视为个体的概念、我们将自己视为集体一部分的程度有关。这并不一定意味着，你知道，亚裔和英裔儿童在生物学上彼此不同。
But the experiment that you are citing really reveals that we have in some ways different frames. So autonomy means something different for the Anglo kids than it did for the Asian kids. So what was it? Well, I think in American culture, we have a very deep assumption, which goes like this. If a choice affects me, I should be the one to make it. By God. I'm the one who should make that choice. If it's going to affect me, how could you possibly think otherwise?
但你引用的实验确实表明，我们在某些方面有不同的框架。因此，自主权对英裔儿童和亚裔儿童来说意味着不同的东西。那么它是什么呢？嗯，我认为在美国文化中，我们有一个非常深层的假设，大致是这样的：如果一个选择影响了我，我应该就是那个做出选择的人。看在上帝的份上。我是那个应该做出选择的人。如果它要影响我，你怎么可能作别的想法？
And in the Asian culture, they have an equally valid assumption, which says, if a choice affects me and is important, then by God, somebody really important to me is going to tell me, you're a sister, you're a guide me on how to make that choice. How could you do it any other way? And that's an example of how a choice should be made, what constitutes a good or bad choice-making method? These are cultural constructs.
而在亚洲文化中，他们有一个同样有效的假设，它说：如果一个选择影响了我并且很重要，那么看在上帝的份上，对我很重要的人会告诉我，你是我的姐妹，你会指导我如何做出那个选择。你怎么能用任何其他方式去做呢？这就是应该如何做出选择的一个例子，什么构成了一种好或坏的选择方法？这些都是文化建构。
So the takeaway here is not only do cultures differ in how many choices people get, they also differ in how desirable they think it is to have choices. Some cultures see less choices, the root to happiness and strive to limit choices and other cultures see more choice as the path to happiness. You encountered this in your own life when you were working in Japan and at a restaurant one day you asked for a cup of tea. Can you tell me what happened next? So I was in Japan. This was in 1995. I was a PhD student and I was in Kyoto. And I, you know, as an Indian, I grew up with tea that had sugar. Of course, you put sugar
所以这里的核心观点是，不仅不同文化在人们拥有的选择数量上有所不同，它们在认为拥有选择有多大 desirable（渴望程度）上也不尽相同。有些文化将较少的选择视为通往幸福的途径并努力限制选择，而另当别的文化则将更多的选择视为通往幸福的路径。你自己在日本工作时就曾遇到过这种情况，当时你在一家餐厅要了一杯茶。你能告诉我后来发生了什么吗？当时我在日本。那是1995年。我是一名博士生，在京都。而且，你知道的，作为一个印度人，我从小喝的茶都是加糖的。当然，你会往茶里加糖
in your tea. And so I go to this Japanese restaurant and I order green tea and I say, can I please have some sugar? And the waiter says, oh, I don't know, you don't put sugar in tea. And I said, yeah, I understand in Japan, you don't put sugar in your tea, but can I please have some sugar with my tea? And in Japanese style, this leads to this big discussion and how multiple people are coming to me verifying I want sugar. Ultimately the manager comes to me and says I'm sorry we don't have sugar. And so then I'm like well I don't want green tea if I can't have sugar so I order a cup of coffee. And they bring me a cup of coffee and with the cup of coffee they brought me two packets of sugar.
所以我去了一家日本餐厅，点了绿茶，然后我说，能给我一些糖吗？服务员说，哦，我不知道，你们不往茶里加糖。我说，是的，我知道在日本茶里不加糖，但我能给我的茶加点糖吗？按照日本人的风格，这引发了一场大讨论，多个人跑来向我核实我是不是真的想要糖。最后经理走过来对我说，对不起，我们没有糖。然后我就想，如果不能加糖，我才不要喝绿茶，于是我点了一杯咖啡。他们端来了一杯咖啡，并且随着这杯咖啡，他们给我拿了两包糖。
And it wasn't that they were trying to be obtuse or rude. They were just trying to protect me from, you know, making a fool of myself. I mean, you can't put sugar in green tea. It's just not done. I was just trying to protect me from my base or instincts. One thing I take away from the story is that there isn't a one-size-fits-all rule for everybody when it comes to choice. So in other words, an arranged marriage might work for one couple, but it might be a disastrous idea for another.
并不是说他们故意显得生硬或粗鲁。他们只是想保护我，免得我出丑。我的意思是，你不能往绿茶里加糖。这是绝对不允许的。我只是想保护自己免受本能的驱使。我从这个故事中得到的启示之一是，在选择方面，并不存在一个适用于所有人的“一刀切”规则。换句话说，包办婚姻对一对夫妇可能管用，但对另一对夫妇来说可能是场灾难。
The love marriage and the arranged marriage as tempting as it is to want to compare them. They're just very different models, right? An arranged marriage assumes that marriage is conceived in fate. Kind of like a parent and a child, right? It's conceived in fate. This is not something you break. And so when you're stuck with somebody, you just bring a different mindset to it, right? You know you have to work it out and adapt. A love marriage is conceived in choice. And so you're going to treat it differently, you know,
爱情婚姻和包办婚姻，尽管我们很想去比较它们，但它们其实是非常不同的模式，对吧？包办婚姻假设婚姻是命中注定的。有点像父母和孩子，对吧？它是命中注定的。这不是你可以打破的东西。所以，当你和某人绑在一起时，你只是会带着一种不同的心态去对待它，对吧？你知道你必须去解决它并去适应它。而爱情婚姻则是基于选择而构成的。所以你会以不同的方式对待它，你知道的，
because you have different expectations from it. So I think that's one thing to pay attention to that, you know, they are conceived of in different ways and so they're gonna bring different expectations for the two sets of participants. I think the second thing to keep in mind is that they are matching people based on different criteria. In an arranged marriage, they are going to take care of the stuff that could cause problems pretty up front, right? They're usually people of the same religion, the same caste, the parents know each other,
因为你对它有着不同的期望。所以我觉得这是需要注意的一点，你知道的，它们的构成方式不同，因此它们会给两组参与者带来不同的期望。我认为第二件需要记住的事情是，它们是基于不同的标准来匹配人们的。在包办婚姻中，他们会提前处理好那些可能引起问题的因素，对吧？他们通常是同一宗教、同一种姓的人，双方父母互相认识，
generally speaking, they're similar demographics, economics, et cetera. And so by and large, you do have people that are a bit more similar coming together. So at least you get a bunch of those things out of the way that they're probably not gonna fight about. And remember, they don't have this goal necessarily of feeling of, well, a good marriage is one where I have to want to, you know, take this person's clothes off every day.
一般来说，他们有相似的人口统计特征、经济状况等等。因此，大体上说，聚在一起的人确实会更相似一些。所以至少你可以先把那些他们可能不会争吵的事情抛诸脑后。请记住，他们不一定有这种感觉的目标，即“一段美好的婚姻就是那种我每天都想脱掉这个人的衣服的婚姻”。
That's just not their vision of what the ideal marriage is, right? Whereas in the love marriage, it's, you know, it's about being compatible in terms of, oh my God, I have this special feeling every time I see this person. And at the very least, I want to tear off their clothes. And on top of that, we have some amazing conversations. And we get along and we share in values. They're just going to judge them by very different criteria. Sheena has come up with a number of strategies to help people make better choices.
这根本不是他们对理想婚姻的愿景，对吧？而在爱情婚姻中，你知道的，它是关于“天哪，每次我看到这个人我都有这种特别的感觉”的兼容性。最起码，我想撕掉他们的衣服。最重要的是，我们能进行精彩的对话。我们相处融洽，价值观相同。他们只是会用非常不同的标准来评判它们。希娜提出了一系列策略来帮助人们做出更好的选择。
One insight came from a study she conducted where people were given the option to customize the cars they were buying. Let's imagine you are custom making your car. And you have to make roughly 60 decisions, right? The rear view mirror, the steering wheel, the roof, the interior decor, the exterior car color, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Now, per decision, you have a variable number of choices, right?
一个见解来自于她进行的一项研究，在该研究中，人们被赋予了定制他们所购买汽车的选项。让我们想象一下，你正在定制你的汽车。你必须做出大约60个决定，对吧？后视镜、方向盘、车顶、内饰、车身颜色，对吧，对吧，对吧，对吧。现在，每个决定你都有数量不等的选择，对吧？
So for an engine, you might have two, for exterior car color, you might have 56 different colors. So it turns out that if I organize your choosing experience so that you go from easy choices, meaning you're choosing two engines and then 10 different types of, say, steering wheels and then 21 different types of interior decor, steering wheels and then 21 different types of interior decor. It's just getting gradually more complex until you get to the 56 different car colors.
比如对于发动机，你可能有2种选择；对于汽车车身颜色，你可能有56种不同的颜色。事实证明，如果我组织你的选择体验，让你从简单的选择开始，这意味着你选择2种发动机，然后是10种不同类型的，比方说方向盘，然后是21种不同类型的内饰，方向盘，然后是21种不同类型的内饰。它只是逐渐变得越来越复杂，直到你面对56种不同的汽车颜色。
Versus, you go from high choice scenarios, 56 car colors and then it's gradually getting less and less and less such that the last choice you make you're choosing two engines. It turns out if you go from low choice to high choice, you remain motivated and interested in that call. How do we know that? Well, per decision, if you don't know what to choose, you hit the default button. And it turns out that when people go from low choice to high choice, they continue to choose. When they go from high choice to low choice, they start off with enthusiasm, but somewhere in the middle of the choosing process, they just start hitting the default button over
相比之下，如果你从高选择场景开始，即56种汽车颜色，然后逐渐减少、减少、再减少，以至于你做的最后一个选择是选择2种发动机。事实证明，如果你从低选择走向高选择，你会对这辆车保持积极性和兴趣。我们怎么知道的呢？好吧，对于每一个决定，如果你不知道该选什么，你就会点击默认按钮。事实证明，当人们从低选择走向高选择时，他们会继续做出选择。而当他们从高选择走向低选择时，他们一开始满腔热情，但在选择过程的某个中间阶段，他们开始不停地点击默认按钮，
and over and over again. They're also less satisfied with the card that they have just put over 30,000 euros to buy if they go from high choice to low choice, much more satisfied when they go from low to high choice. Now, what are the ramifications of that? It means that there's a, you know, we like customization, that's the whole point of modern living, right? You can have personalization, which enables us to be unique and have it exactly the way we want and apps, et cetera, and make it a lot easier for us to do that. But it also means that you have to make
一次又一次。如果他们从高选择走向低选择，他们对刚刚花3万多欧元买下的车的满意度也会较低；而当他们从低选择走向高选择时，满意度要高得多。现在，这会带来什么影响呢？这意味着，我们喜欢定制，这就是现代生活的全部意义，对吧？你可以拥有个性化，这让我们能够保持独特并精确获得我们想要的东西，还有各种应用程序等，这使我们做起来容易得多。但这同时也意味着你必须
that choosing experience curated in a way that they're actually intrinsically motivating, right? You can't just throw me into the deep end. Take me in little by little by little. Start me off with an easy choice, then gradually make it harder and harder. You need to start me off so that I know what I'm choosing. I'm starting to imagine what I'm putting together.
以一种能够真正激发内在动力的方式来策划这种选择体验，对吧？你不能直接把我扔进深水区。一点一点、循序渐进地带我进去。从简单的选择开始，然后逐渐增加难度。你需要从让我知道我在选择什么开始。我开始想象我在拼凑什么。
The more excited I get, the more I'm able to imagine this thing I'm creating. The more I'm going to be able to put in the mental energy that it takes to deal with those increasingly more complex choices that you're going to give me. I'm wondering if there is an element of this that's also about the forest and the trees. You've also, I think, talked about this idea that it's important to choose sort of bigger categories rather than start out with smaller categories. So maybe you want to decide do I want a hybrid or do I not want a hybrid before you get bogged down and sort of the differences between the specifics to make the higher level choices
我越兴奋，我就越能想象出我正在创造的这个东西。我就越能够投入完成你将给我的那些日益复杂的选择所需的精神能量。我想知道其中是否也有一个关于树木与森林的元素。我想你也谈过这个想法，即选择更大的类别，而不是从更小的类别开始，这一点很重要。所以也许你想在陷入具体细节的差异之前，先决定我是想要一辆混合动力车还是不想要一辆混合动力车，以便先做出更高层次的选择。
first. Do you think the two ideas are connected? Do the forests before the trees? Oh absolutely. I mean when you're going to give people tons of choices, hands down those websites which will have a real competitive advantage is the way they organize the choices, making the categories you have to make the categories meaningful, not cutesy. You have to make the categories one where I clearly know without much thought, oh, that one is more applicable to me and that one is not. The more people can feel confident about saying no to the stuff they don't want. And yes, I am interested in something more in that category and I can start whittling it down.
你认为这两个概念是相联的吗？先见森林再见树木？哦，当然。我的意思是，当你要给人们提供大量的选择时，毫无疑问，那些真正具有竞争优势的网站将是那些组织选择的方式，使你必须让类别变得有意义，而不是花哨可爱。你必须让类别变得清晰，让我无需太多思考就能明确地知道：那个对我和更适用，而那个不适用。人们越能自信地说不对于他们不想要的东西。
Happier I am in the choosing experience. By the way, I think to the extent that anybody can do that with the dating apps, the better off people will also be, because literally the swiping right and left, it's not actually helping, even though it might feel good to keep swiping, it's not actually good for the experience of feeling confident or competent during that choosing process. One of the things that you've talked about, and I understand you're writing a new book about the subject, is that choice gives us the ability to imagine futures that we might not have been able to imagine
并且是的，我对那个类别中更多的东西感兴趣，我就可以开始缩小范围。我在选择体验中就越快乐。顺便说一句，我认为任何人如果能在约会软件上做到这一点，人们的处境也会更好，因为实际上，向右和向左滑动并没有真正起到帮助作用，尽管不断滑动可能会感觉很好，但它实际上不利于在整个选择过程中感到自信或胜任的体验。你谈到的事情之一，据我所知你正在写一本关于这个主题的新书，那就是选择赋予了我们想象未来能力，而这些未来是我们可能无法想象的
otherwise. Can you talk about this utility that choice gives us and how it's connected to the new book you're working on? So I really think that the real power of choice does not come from the ability to pick and find. I mean, obviously we spend our lives picking and finding from morning until night, but I think the real power of choice, what really distinguishes us from everything, whether it be other animals, whether it be AI and machine learning, is our ability to imagine and turn what we imagine into a real choice. So one of my favorite quotes is a quote by the French polymath Anouille Procaré who said that invention consists of avoiding the constructing of useless combinations and consists of the constructing of useful combinations
否则的话。你能谈谈这种由选择赋予我们的效用，以及它如何与你正在创作的新书相关联吗？所以我真的认为，选择真正的力量并不来自于挑选和寻找的能力。我的意思是，很显然我们的一生都是从早到晚在挑选和寻找，但我认为选择真正的力量，真正让我们与一切区分开来的东西——无论是其他动物还是人工智能和机器学习——是我们想象的能力，以及将我们想象的东西转化为真实选择的能力。因此，我最喜欢的一句话是法国全才昂利·庞加莱的名言，他说：“发明包括避免构建无用的组合，并包括构建有用的组合”，
which are an infinite minority. To invent is to discern is to choose. And so I often tell my students a corollary. And my corollary is that to choose is to invent, that we can use choice to construct those most meaningful combinations. And that's when we really experienced the power of choice. That choice is not about being reactive to whatever is in front of you.
“而这些有用的组合是无限的少数。”发明就是辨别，就是选择。所以我经常告诉我的学生一个推论。我的推论是：选择就是发明，我们可以利用选择来构建那些最有意义的组合。这就是我们真正体验到选择的力量的时候。选择不是对你面前的任何东西做出被动反应。
It's being able to be proactive about creating those choices that enable you to go from who you are today to whom you want to be tomorrow. And so that's my link to imagination. So in many ways this leads me to a personal question I wanted to ask you, Shina. As a child, you had dreamed of becoming a pilot. I want you to tell me why that childhood dream did not pan out. And what that disappointment taught you about the world of choices and what you were just talking about a second earlier, the world of constructing your own choices. So when I was a kid, I was diagnosed with a written-itis pigmentosa, and so I had a rare form of it,
它是能够积极主动地创造那些能让你从今天的自己转变为明天的你想成为的自己的选择。这就是我与想象力的联系。所以在很多方面，这引导我问你一个我想问的个人问题，希娜。小时候，你曾梦想成为一名飞行员。我想让你告诉我，为什么那个童年梦想没有实现？那次失望教会了你关于选择世界的什么，以及你刚才提到的创造你自己的选择的世界？所以当我还是个孩子的时候，我被诊断出患有视网膜色素变性，我得的是一种罕见的形式，
and so my parents were told that I would go blind sometime during my school years. And, you know, as often happens when parents are confronted by this, they don't really know what to do, they don't know what options they, we might have, and in many cases they were kind of hoping it would go away, and it was kept a secret. And I remember the first time when I was in school I was in second grade and our teacher had just finished telling us that we could grow up and do and be whatever it is we wanted to be as long as we put our hearts and minds to it. And so she asked us what did we want to be when we grew up.
因此我的父母被告知我会在上学期间的某个时候失明。而且，你知道的，当父母面对这种情况时经常发生的那样，他们真的不知道该怎么办，他们不知道我们可能有什么选择，在许多情况下，他们有点希望它会消失，并且它被保密了。我记得第一次是在我上学的时候，我读二年级，我们的老师刚刚讲完，只要我们全心全意地去做，我们长大后就可以做任何我们想做的事，成为任何我们想成为的人。所以她问我们长大后想做什么。
And I raised my hand, I was about like eight years old at the time, and I said I was gonna be a pilot, and everybody's snickered. And because you know, the teacher knew that I had some visual challenges and the kids knew, and that was actually probably the first time when I really began to understand that you can't just put your heart into it. There are constraints.
我举起了手，当时我大约八岁左右，我说我要成为一名飞行员，所有人都嗤之以鼻。因为你知道，老师知道我有一些视力问题，孩子们也知道，那可能实际上是我真正开始明白你不能仅仅把心血倾注其中的时刻。这里存在着限制。
You are going to have to figure out what choices are available to you. And I think that's true for all of us, right? We're all trying to figure out what our limitations are. And in part of that has to do with being able to differentiate between our perceived and true limitations. And that was certainly one of my big struggles growing up. I was figuring that because there were lots of people that had lots of views about what a blind person could and could not do and what choices they had and didn't have. And so I had to look at that information and I had to look at the information of, well, what could I do and not do? Isn't it possible that there are other choices available that go
你将不得不弄清楚有哪些选择适合你。我想这对我们所有人都适用，对吧？我们都在试图弄清楚我们的局限性是什么。其中一部分与能够区分我们感知到的局限性和真实的局限性有关。这无疑是我成长过程中的一大挣扎。我发现，因为有很多人对盲人能做什么和不能做什么、他们有什么选择和没有选择有着各种各样的看法。所以我必须审视这些信息，我必须审视关于我能做什么和不能做什么的信息，难道没有可能还有其他可用的选择超出
beyond this choice set that other people are telling me about? You write in your book that to choose means to turn ourselves to the future, to try to catch a glimpse of the next hour, the next year. Right now in the midst of the COVID-19 pandemic, many of us can't see what's ahead. We don't know when a vaccine is going to come, what's going to happen to the economy. Many of us are experiencing a deep loss of control. I'm wondering what your own experience with blindness may have taught you about having control,
其他人告诉我的这个选择集吗？你在书中写道，选择意味着转向未来，试图窥视下一个小时、下一年。现在在COVID-19大流行的阴影下，我们许多人看不到前方。我们不知道疫苗什么时候会来，经济会发生什么。我们许多人正在经历深深的失控感。我想知道你自己的失明经历可能教会了你关于掌控、
not having control, and making choices that would produce happiness in the future. So I would say that there are three things that I keep as sort of models in my life. One is you always have to be choosing about choosing. And that is that there's so many things coming at you, you have to somehow remind yourself, what are the three most important things right now?
失去掌控，以及做出能在未来带来幸福的抉择。所以我想说，我在生活中保留了三种作为模式的东西。第一是，你必须时刻在对选择进行选择。也就是说，有如此多的事情向你袭来，你必须以某种方式提醒自己，当前最最重要的三件事是什么？
And I try to keep it to no more than five and really prefer three because my brain can't handle more than that. And by the way, everything I'm saying I certainly things that I try to practice right now during the crisis. The second thing is, each day I ask myself, what is the bare minimum that I absolutely have
我尽量将其保持在不超过五个，并且真的更倾向于三个，因为我的大脑无法处理比这更多的东西。顺便说一句，我所说的一切绝对是我现在在危机期间努力践行的东西。第二件事是，我每天问自己，今天我绝对必须
to accomplish today? That's really important to accomplish today. Everything else I get done is icing. And, you know, that makes life a lot easier because then you understand, okay, of, you know, what's the bare minimum? Like, make sure 14 year old son stays alive. It's bare minimum. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, control over. And so you're better able to let go of the stuff you don't have as much control over. The third thing that I keep in mind is that, you know, in life we have lots of dreams. And one of the great things about being a human being is that we're endlessly dreaming. And we always have great dreams. And most of those dreams we have to take off the table.
完成的底线是什么？今天必须完成的非常重要的事情。我完成的所有其他事情都是锦上添花。而且，你知道，这让生活变得容易得多，因为这样你就明白了，好吧，在，你知道的，什么是底线？比如，确保14岁的儿子活着。这就是底线。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不流，
They're gone. They're just not possible. And that's really sad. But the reality is that as humans, dreams come in an endless supply pack. And so you can focus on the dreams that you can make and you can take advantage of. And that's really where the power of choice comes from. advantage of, and that's really where the power of choice comes from. Psychologist Shina Aengar works at Columbia University. Shina, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you.
利用，而这正是选择的力量的真正来源。心理学家希娜·埃恩加尔在哥伦比亚大学工作。希娜，谢谢你今天加入我们的《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。
This episode was produced by Lu Shik Waba and Paath Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle and Kat Schuchnick, production support from Gilly Moon. Hidden Brain has a request for you. We'd like to better understand who's listening and how you're using podcasts. Please help us out by completing a short, anonymous survey at npr.org slash podcast survey. It takes less than 10 minutes and really helps support the show. That'sung hero this week is Kate Turner. Kate works as an assistant to Sheena Iangar
本期节目由卢·希克·瓦巴和帕斯·沙制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩剪辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和卡特·舒赫尼克，制作支持来自吉利·穆恩。《隐藏的大脑》有一个请求。我们想更好地了解谁在收听以及您是如何使用播客的。请在 npr.org 上的播客调查页面填写一份简短的匿名调查来帮我们一把。这只需要不到10分钟，并且对支持本节目有很大帮助。本周的无名英雄是凯特·特纳。凯特担任希娜·埃恩加尔的助理
and she was essential to making our interview possible. Before the interview, Kate took time to test out an app to record the conversation and then made sure we were getting the best sound quality possible. She deleted many megabytes of files from her phone to clear space for the interview recordings. Thank you for your diligence and your patience. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like today's
她对促成我们的采访起到了至关重要的作用。在采访之前，凯特花时间测试了一个用于录制对话的应用程序，然后确保我们获得了尽可能好的音质。她从手机中删除了许多兆字节的文件，以腾出空间来存放采访录音。感谢您的勤奋和耐心。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。如果你喜欢今天的
show, please share it with a friend. I know I ask you to do this every week, but I really mean it. If you like today's episode, please think of someone who doesn't know about hidden brain and share it with them. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目，请把它分享给朋友。我知道我每周都请你这样做，但我确实是认真的。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请想想一个不知道《隐藏的大脑》的人并分享给他们。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。这个节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。